[Music]
tail ears so easy whoa whoa whoa hold on
now you're gonna learn how to act like a
cat I'm gonna throw some situations at
you and you're just gonna react like a
cat no touching is for dopes you're
above life until in the face okay
search the butt to the cop walk on
keyboard there you go
coffee on computer and down yes you got
it you're as close to a cat as a dog can
get the secret life for fish to eat
sweet pea what cats eat birds you're
seriously gonna make are you sweet Pete
oh no no of course I'm no bad dog bad
cat dog oh sorry
[Music]
what you're about to hear is the most
dramatic thing you ever heard in your
whole life do any of you know captain
snowball yeah yes yes we do and here we
go
my name is Stacy and I really gotta talk
to him I don't mean to sound dramatic
though a poor defenseless animal needs
saving
I'm he captain okay anyway probably you
you're wearing a bright suit everyone's
gonna notice you I'll be fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No why is there lampshade on your heel
my owner might have given me a little
bit of catnip oh okay gotcha do you hear
that
oh you're pouring oh I wonder what other
sounds I could make
are you finished hi I'm home
let's say we go for a walk this is nice
[Music]
first time here uh yeah
dr. Francis is the best veterinarian in
that business you're gonna love him he
specializes in behavioral disorders but
I don't have a behavioral disorder I I'm
fine too it's by human that's nuts I
mean you know I I bring him a dead bird
she throws it out I bring him a dead
mouse garbage I've gone no no my owner
always says you're such a good dog and I
feel like a good dog of us what if deep
down I'm a bad dog bad dog we start
fires
that was weird Oh sister it's gonna get
way weirder
[Music]
here's that good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing
until a superhero stuff I'm calling this
meeting of the superhero animal friends
to order come on Molly
time to go oh I'm gonna be late for
school captain snowball you're in charge
while I'm gone
mom first of all I want to welcome white
thunder back from the washing machine
who was put in there with a red blanket
and henceforth will be known as pink
Thunder personally I like the new look
[Music]